his progress inevitable well of course
not progress does not mean that
everything gets better for everyone
everywhere all the time that would be
magic not progress progress consists of
using knowledge to solve problems and
problems are inevitable solutions create
new problems which have to be solved in
their turn also the world can always be
blindsided by nasty surprises and I've
mentioned a number of them the world
wars the 1960's crime boom AIDS in
Africa the American opioid epidemic and
there are severe global challenges that
we have not solved for most among them
being climate change and the risk of
nuclear war I think it is best to see
these not as apocalypse as in waiting
but as solvable but as yet unsolved
problems more generally progress is not
a mystical force but it depends on
embracing the ideals of the
Enlightenment namely applying reason in
science to enhance human flourishing if
we continue to apply these principles
then progress could continue and if we
don't it may not
[Music]